July 8 through Saturday July 7th 11th
we're gonna be airing our shows from
comic-con in San Diego and this is kind
of cool the company that makes pop toys
Funko has created some conan pop toys
they're already popped toys for Star
Wars game of Thrones Breaking Bad The
Walking Dead so this is kind of a that's
a big honor and there are four of them
that are going to be out there and
available and they sent them to us today
and yeah they're kind of cool you see
different Conan's there's regular Conan
there's Batman Conan
they're very there's zombie Conan which
is what I look like dead and Conan
monster which is me at rehearsal and
those are pretty cool yeah so they made
four different versions of you they
couldn't make any of anyone else on the
show okay that's a good point
well sorry I'm sorry I mean you're not a
zombie no I'm sorry
in fact I knew you might feel left out
so just before the show I went to the
trouble of having the prop guys make
this exclusive and ego
this is an exclusive that
once-in-a-lifetime specially crafted
Andy Richter doll now that's a used
Cabbage Patch Kid that you just slapped
a tie on cuz yeah I think it's a girl it
is a girl yeah but I look so much like
you plus we ready to say classic Andy
catchphrases baby I want to go home
early I took a nap and now I'm gonna
take another nap you got a reveal Andy
that's a classic lady line anyway huh I
always wanted to comfort my yeah for
therapy we're gonna be giving away a ton
of pop conan toys during our week at
comic-con for free look for details on
how you can get one at Team Coco calm
slash Comic Con keep these in the box
and one day each one will be worth $11
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography